(baby cooing)
(water trickling)
- [Woman] My mind kept
repeating a single thought:
He had taken from me my innocence,
my youth, my heart.
Everything.
(water splashing)
So I took from him the only thing I could.
(Ying-Ying screaming)
- Really, nobody's
gonna crack open a book?
- They're in there.
- Why do they lock this?
- So we don't steal them.
- You're here for the engineering club?
- I'd like to enter this.
- [Woman] The fifth annual
Underwater Robotics Competition.
- So you wanna go up against
the best tech schools in the country?
- Says they scout for
internships, and jobs.
- You guys got some ground to make up.
The other teams will
have more money than you.
- So you're still short $432.54.
- And my man ate a couple
ice creams on the way in.
- Can I have an ice cream?
- Too late.
I already wrote the check.
Okay, we gotta find cheap,
creative ways to build this thing.
(zapping)
(student screams)
- How do we fix it?
- We gotta stop this leak.
- [Fredi] Small and really absorbent.
(cheering)
- Next case.
- [Clerk] City of Atlanta
versus Mabel Simmons.
- Hey, Cora.
- Hey.
- Hey, Brown.
If the Lord get me out of
this, I'm going by the church.
- You better mean it, too.
- I'm going by the church.
- You better mean it.
- I mean it.
Hey, Judge.
Oh, girl, your hair is so pretty.
Who doing your hair?
Lord have mercy.
How you doing?
- Mabel Simmons, you come before me
more than you go to the
doctor for a checkup.
- Listen, I done changed my life.
You ain't got to say nothing.
I am living for the Lord.
- Since when?
- I am living for the Lord.
I am living for the Lord.
- Mabel-
- Hallelujah.
I feel him down in my spirit.
You know, as I think about
the goodness of Jesus
and all that he has done for me,
my soul cries out, "Hallelujah,
thank God for saving me."
- [Mablean] You finished?
- Mm-hmm.
- Hello, everyone,
and welcome to the Academy's
Visiting Artists Film Series,
FilmAid Edition for Film Editing.
I'm Dody Dorn here in Los Angeles.
I'm a governor of the Academy
in the Editor's Branch.
I have the distinct pleasure
of introducing Maysie Hoy,
who I've known for over 40 years.
(Maysie chuckles)
A long time.
(laughs) And I'm very proud and humbled
to be able to introduce her to you.
The amazing Maysie Hoy.
- Thank you, Dody.
I mean, people don't
know that Dody herself
is a well-respected
editor in her own right.
So she has a great body of work.
So get onto the web and
check out her resume.
Anyways, hi to everyone.
My name is Maysie Hoy.
I'm a film editor, and I
live in Los Angeles as well.
And I guess, where do we start, Dody?
From the beginning?
- Yeah, first I just wanna thank
you so much for doing this.
It really means a lot
to the students, I know,
and other people out there
who are watching this.
So it's really great that you're willing
to share your time and your experiences.
And I would just love to know
how you first got started
in the film industry.
- Well, it's...
I started out as an actress,
living in Vancouver.
And at a very, very young age,
this is very strange,
I think as far back as I can remember,
when I was like, four or five years old,
this is what I wanted to do.
Which is crazy because where I grew up
with very traditional parents,
being Chinese and very, very old school,
that was the furthest
thing from their minds
of what I should be doing.
And so with that in the back of my mind,
it just sort of...
To please my family, I told
them I wanted to be a nurse,
but when I graduated I said,
"Okay, I don't know how
I'm gonna get into the film business,
but I'll go and study to be a dietician."
And then in my spare time
I could find acting work.
And so one day I'm in the
cafeteria of this college
and I see all these students having fun.
They were just having a great time.
So I approached them and I said,
"Can I ask you what
classes you guys are in,
or what's your major?"
And they go, "Theater arts."
I go, "Oh wow, that's great."
I said, "I didn't even know
they had a theater arts program here."
And I said, "Well, how do I get in it?"
And they said, "Well, first of all,
you go to your counselor
and ask to be transferred."
I said, "Okay, great."
So I head off to the counselor's office.
And you've gotta understand
that Vancouver is a very
provincial kind of city.
In fact, very stoic, very English.
So I walked into the counselor's office,
and there's a woman
sitting behind the desk,
gray hair with big bun.
She was really, really nice.
And I said to her, I said,
"Look, I wanna transfer out
of the dietician program
and get into the theater arts program."
And she kinda looked at me and said,
"Well, are you sure
this is what you want?"
I says, "Yeah, this is something
I've dreamed of doing all my life."
And she goes, "You know, there's
not gonna be a lot of work
for somebody like you."
And I look at her and I go,
"Well, it doesn't matter."
I said, "This is what I wanna do,
so can you please sign the transfer
for me to get into the theater program?"
So she signed it,
and off I went to the
basement of this college.
And I walked in, and there was this very
English-looking gentleman
who ran the program.
And it was Tony Holland.
He had worked at the
Bristol Old Vic in London,
and now he was living in Vancouver
and he was head of this theater program.
So I gave him the transfer note,
and he looked at the transfer note,
he looked up at me a couple times,
and he goes, "Why do you wanna do this?"
And I go, "Well, I wanna be an actress."
And he said basically the same thing.
He goes, "You know,
there's not a lot of work
for somebody like you."
And I looked at him, I go,
"Just let me in the class.
You don't even have to talk to me,
you don't have to bother me.
Just let me in the class."
So he did.
And it's interesting
because many years later
I became good friends with his wife.
Her name was Gusta, and she said to me,
she says, "You know, he came home that day
and he said, 'Can you believe it?
There's this Chinese woman
that wants to be an actress.
And besides, she's not
that pretty.'" (laughs)
And so anyways, I always
used this against him
because when I see him after I graduated
and came to Hollywood and
made a career of myself,
he would always look at
me sheepishly and say,
"I'm really, really sorry
about what I said to you."
I said, "You know what?
What that did was it motivated
me to create my own program,
or find my own way."
So once again,
I'm sitting in my friend's
apartment, and she said,
"You know, they're casting
this movie in town."
I go...
Well, it's Robert Altman.
He's doing a movie called
"McCabe and Mrs. Miller".
And so she says, "You know what?
You should see if you can get on that."
And so then at the time,
I met somebody who,
at that time, at a book of actors.
And I got involved in that.
You know, they take your picture,
they put it in this book
and they give it to the casting directors.
And so one day I get this phone call
from somebody called Graham Clifford.
Graham now is a director,
but he was the casting director.
So he brought me in, and
we sat and we talked a lot.
And so then I sort of left it.
And he goes, "Well,
Bob is gonna be in town
in about a month, so I'm
gonna keep you in mind,
so just stay in touch."
And so I get a phone call
from Robert Altman's office,
and Graham said, "Well,
Bob wants to meet you."
And so I said, "Okay."
At that time I didn't have a car,
but I took a bus, which took about an hour
to get to where Bob was.
And anyways, I walked in,
and I think he was sick.
I mean, he was laying around on a couch.
And he looked up at me, he goes,
"I don't stand for whores."
And I go...
At that point I knew I got the job
because in "McCabe and Mrs. Miller",
the only women's parts in
that movie were prostitutes.
(laughs) And so that's
how I met Robert Altman.
And so from that point
on, I was in that movie.
And when I finished the movie,
I couldn't get any work, you know?
I think I got a job on
a CBC film, a series,
and I played a receptionist.
And so, that was about it.
They weren't casting Asian women.
And this is before
Vancouver became the place
to shoot movies and television shows,
because when I left, they
created an incentive.
So the nickname for
Vancouver is Hollywood North.
After being unemployed for a while,
I'd take odd jobs just so that,
you know, pay the rent
and things like that.
And so I finally said to,
once again, my friend Joan in
the basement of her apartment,
I said, "You know what?
I've gotta get out of here,"
because if anybody's
ever been to Vancouver,
they call Vancouver part of
the Northwest Rainforest.
So it rains 360 days out of 365 days.
And I says, "I gotta get out of here.
I can't stand this rain anymore."
So she says, "Have you thought about
writing to Robert Altman?"
And I go, "Well, that's an idea."
So I wrote to him.
Never heard back.
And then I read in the trades
that he was doing this picture
called "California Split".
I had no idea what it was.
So I just made a random phone
call to him in California.
And I reintroduced myself to him.
And I said, "You know what?
I'd like to come to
California, to Los Angeles,
and just sort of shadow you
because I wanna be a director."
And he said to me, he
goes, "Do you play poker?"
And I go, "Well, I can learn.
Sort of.
I kinda know how to play poker."
And he goes, "Okay, be here January 13th."
I swear to God, within a week I was gone.
And I tell people this story because,
my parents being immigrants,
had very little English...
Understood very little English.
So I said to my mother on
the day I was leaving...
I mean, they sort of had an
idea I was up to something.
And so I left.
I only knew two people,
Robert Altman and a kid
I went to church with,
I knew he was going to Art Center.
And I knew I had a place
to stay for a week.
So I had my sleeping bag
and my backpack, and I left.
And I'll tell you the
weirdest thing that happened,
was the minute I landed in Los Angeles,
I knew this was where I belonged.
- That's great.
That's fantastic.
- You know, your feet hit
the ground and it was like,
okay, it just...
This is where you're supposed to be.
- I love that.
I love that.
you know, that was just what I would call
a masterclass in moxie, (laughs)
because you just took these small scraps,
or little strings of opportunities
and turned them into your life.
And it's a fantastic story.
I love it.
- I think I was dumb to know
that that's not what you do, you know?
Call up a director, you know, like that.
But yeah.
It was interesting
because when I got on the set,
I looked around at all these
different departments, right?
And I kinda made a plan in my head.
And I go, okay, this is what I'm gonna do.
I'm in a situation where
I could learn a lot
from these different people.
And so I decided,
okay, I'm gonna create my own
Robert Altman film school.
So every day I would spend...
'Cause they would see me on the set.
The crew would see me on the
set and they always wondered,
who is this person?
What is she doing here?
And so when I explained to them
that I knew Bob and I was
in his movie, and I got...
It was an interesting dynamic
because then they looked
at me in a different way.
They were very...
Everybody on the crew was very helpful.
And I think that I was
protected by knowing him.
So nobody treated me badly,
even though the guys
were trying to hit on me.
And that was like, (laughs) you know,
part of the environment.
And so I decided, okay, let's see,
today I'm gonna spend the
day with the sound people.
And that was with Jimmy
Webb and Chris McLoughlin.
And at that time, he was just
creating the 8-track sound.
So I would sit with them
and ask them questions.
They were very helpful.
They didn't say, "Beat it, kid."
And then the next day I would spend it
with the electrical department,
where I met my future husband.
I didn't know this. (laughs)
And then the next day I would hang out
with the camera people,
and the script supervisor
and the wardrobe people
because I could sew.
And I met this lovely wardrobe man.
His name was Huey, and he
had been a wardrobe person
for Fred Astaire and Robert Wagner.
And he took a liking to me.
He was an older gentleman.
And he'd come to work in a
three-piece suit and a fedora.
So I think he must've been like, 70.
And so he whispered to me, he goes,
"Okay, this is what you gotta do, kid.
When they call for wardrobe,
or they call 'Huey,'
you go, 'Here.'
So you replace me.
So you run up and you ask
them, 'What do you need?'
Then they'll say, 'Oh,
go to Elliot's trailer
and grab whatever.
And so that's what you do.
So you run and you get the clothes,
and you come back and
you give it to them."
And so I did that on the set.
(laughs)
And of course, as things would happen,
they went to Reno, Nevada to shoot
some scenes for the casino.
The script supervisor was pregnant.
And I have to backtrack
because when I was on the
set of "California Split",
there was one day Alan
Rudolph was the second AD,
assistant director, came
up to me and he goes,
"Do you know how to hold script?"
I go, "Why?"
He goes, "Well, Carol's sick.
She's got morning sickness real bad."
Says, "Well, do you know
how to hold script?"
I go, "Yeah."
That wasn't true,
because we had video
classes at the college,
and I knew that you time the stop,
and then that was about it.
So I go, "Yeah."
So give me the script.
And here I was, I was holding a script.
And I worked for like,
two days as a script
supervisor on this movie.
And so, anyways.
At that time, Bob looked at me,
like second day or something.
He look at me and he goes,
"You know, you actually
do that pretty well."
I go, "Oh, thanks."
(laughs) And then from that point on,
when we went to Reno,
I also helped with the script supervising.
So from that point on, I
just sort of kept hanging out
at his office, 'cause I had
nowhere else to go, you know?
And these were really nice
people, they were fun.
- Can you give us a
really brief description
of what a script supervisor does?
Because a lot of people,
they don't put those two words together
and have any idea what it means.
Script supervisor.
- Well, the script supervisor take notes.
She sits next to the...
Well, now they're in video village.
But she's the closest
person to the director
because she has to take
care of the continuity,
meaning from scene to scene,
if somebody's wearing a hat in one scene
and the next scene, they
need to be wearing the hat.
They can't not be wearing the hat
because it needs to be consistent.
She also takes care of the
script in terms of the timing.
She writes down the lens
that's used in the filming.
She makes notes whether
it's a visual effect
that they're shooting, or a plate.
She also hands...
When she's done with the day,
she gives the editors
a log of what was shot
and the script pages of
what was shot that day.
And so that's my guide
to what I'd be seeing
in terms of dailies.
And dailies, that's a word we used
for scenes that was shot the day before.
And so when I get the
dailies the next day,
that's what it is.
Is that clear enough, Dody?
- Yeah, no, that's great.
Yeah, because a lot of
people don't understand
that the script supervisor is
really the connection for us,
especially these days
since we don't watch dailies
together anymore on film.
You're getting a lot of
information from the set
to your editing room through
the script supervisor's notes.
So a lot of times I develop a relationship
with the script supervisor
for that reason,
so that I can get the information.
And I just think it's interesting.
Also the script supervisor makes sure
that all the words in the script are said
at least in one take.
- (laughs) Right.
Right.
- That's-
- And also the sound report, right?
You know, sound is very,
very important to us.
Maybe on the set, they
don't care, you know?
And so the script supervisor's
also my go-between
to talk to the director and to the DP,
the director of photography,
the cinematographer,
because if something goes wrong on the set
or you have dailies that are confusing,
or the camera move is kinda weird
in terms of it being shaky,
or what really bothers
me is when an operator
is shooting a closeup on an actor
and he reframes in the middle of a shot.
And you go, how am I gonna use that?
And so instead of going to the producer,
which is a really bad no-no,
I'd go to the script supervisor.
Unless I've been on the set.
When I was working with Tyler,
I would go to the set the
first week of shooting.
And part of it was to sit with him
because when he first started,
he was a stage director.
And so I would sit with him,
and I'd look at framing,
and I'd, you know,
kinda talk to him a little
bit about the scene.
Or I'd just sit and watch.
And I'd develop a relationship
with the cinematographer,
the sound people, the wardrobe
people, the makeup people.
So if anything went wrong after I left,
I can make a phone call to the DP and go,
"Hey, you know what?
I just wanna give you a heads up.
Here's what your camera guy's doing."
I said, "Can you tell him not to do that?"
So that he then knows that
I'm not threatening him,
or causing him problems with the producer,
or even going to the director,
because the director has
a lot on their minds,
and the last thing they wanna hear is,
okay, camera guy is not doing his job.
But on one occasion this happened.
When I was working with Tyler
on "Daddy's Little Girls"
we had a lot of out of focus shots.
And he called me up, he
goes, "What is going on?"
And I go, "Well, I'll
talk to the cameraman
and see what's going on with these guys."
And they said, "Well, the operator said
the actor's moving too
much in this scene."
I go, "That's their job," you know?
To figure out focus if
they're moving back and forth.
I said, "That's not a great excuse."
So from that point on,
Tyler would always ask me,
he goes, "I want you to
tell me what's in focus
and what is out of focus."
- Well, can I go back a little bit
and ask you about what
the transition was like
going from acting to post-production
and what prompted it?
You're kind of in the
middle of answering that,
but then also how your
acting informed your craft
as an editor anyway, in general.
- Well, the transition from
acting to post-production
and eventually to editing
happened when I was
working with Robert Altman.
I became a PA on "Nashville",
and I was PA to the wardrobe department.
After we finished with "Nashville",
Bob decided that he wanted to do
"Buffalo Bill and the Indians".
And it happened that "Buffalo
Bill and the Indians"
was a period piece.
It was set in the 1880s,
and so they needed somebody to do research
on that time period for
the production design,
for the wardrobe, for the dialogue,
and just sort of events
that were happening during the 1880s.
And so he kinda looked at
me and he basically said,
"Okay, you go do the research."
You know, once again,
sitting in the room when it all happened.
And so I started doing the research
on "Buffalo Bill and the Indians".
And then I went on location with them
and was also the PA to
the wardrobe department.
And after we finished shooting,
when we got back to Los Angeles,
I knew the editors from all
the other movies that Bob did.
And so one day I'm
walking down the hallway,
and back in the day of
film, we had trimmed-ins,
where you put the film,
you put the film on hooks,
you'd mark it, and it all
had to go back into rolls
so that the editor, when
they put it up on the KEM,
or the Steenbeck, that
everything was in sync.
And so there must've
been 20 of these bins.
And I'm walking down the hall
and I see two pair of legs,
it was like a cartoon, inside this bin.
And you see all this film flying out,
which was really another big no-no
because you can't have
any scratches on film.
And as an assistant if you tear film,
then you'd have to get a reprint,
which meant it would cost
the company more money.
So I tap this guy.
And I knew who it was.
And I go, "What are you doing?"
And he goes, "I'm looking for two frames."
Now, we're on electronic
editing equipment now.
Two frames is nothing, you know?
But back in the day when
you've got 20 bins of film
and you gotta look for the two frames,
you need somebody to help you.
So I looked at him, I go,
"Well, it looks like you need help."
He goes, "Yes.
We need an apprentice.
We need somebody to put
the stuff together."
And I go, "Well, I think I can do it."
He goes, "Yeah, you can
most definitely do it."
I said, "So?"
He goes, "Well, you gotta go ask Bob."
I go, "Oh, god."
Okay, so I walked across the way,
and at that time, Robert Altman, to me,
was like seven feet tall.
In reality, he was probably 6'1", okay?
I'm five-feet-one.
And so I walk in and he's pacing.
And I was trying to test
what mood he was in.
And so anyways, I go, okay fine,
what is he gonna say, no?
So I walk up, open the
door and walked in, I go,
"Bob, you know, the editors need help
in reconstituting the film."
And I says, "I think I can do it.
They need an apprentice."
And he looked down at me, he goes,
"This isn't a film school, you know?"
And I go, "Well, I know
that, but you know what?
They still need help."
And he kinda looked at me, he goes,
"Okay, if it's okay with the
guys, it's okay with me."
And I go, "It's okay with the guys."
And man, I ran out of that place so fast
before he changed his mind.
So that's how I got into editing.
I became an assistant on "Buffalo Bill"
because he shot like,
a million feet of film,
so it had to be organized.
They had three editors on the show.
And so that's basically
how I got into editing.
And from that, I got a huge
lesson in post-production,
how a film is shot.
And in my background,
I've been so fortunate
growing up in this business,
seeing amazing dailies, knowing where...
Working with a director that knows
exactly where to put the camera.
So when I'm working now,
you just get this feeling.
It's ingrained in my bones that
I know when it's a good shot
or when it just like, oh,
that just doesn't feel right,
because I sat in the room
when Bob would come in
and give notes to the editors.
And I'd sit there and I'd
listen to what he had to say.
And I would kinda look at the film
and kinda try to maybe second guess,
or guess what he was gonna say.
And so that's how I got
into post-production.
And the reason why I decided
that I wanted to be in
editing was because acting,
I didn't want to go out for the one line,
the one line when I was 30,
40, 50, 60, 70, you know?
And I said, "You know,
if I became an editor,
they couldn't judge me
on the way I looked.
They would judge me on my
resume, my body of work.
And if they did, then well
it's too bad for them."
You know?
I don't particularly wanna
work with people like that.
And so in editing a film,
I think that the acting helped me
because I would find the
truth of the character.
You know, when you're acting
you've gotta find the motivation,
you gotta figure out their backstory.
And so as an editor,
I try to put myself in as a character.
- Yeah, that's right.
All the little moments
you're always looking for.
But that's a great lead-in
to this other question
of how you find the best
moments in and out of a scene?
- Well, I think you sit and you watch,
I guess with an actor's
eye and an editor's eye.
And you just listen to the performance
and you watch the
behavior of the character.
And this is where, leaving the scene,
I know about timing
because that's where my
improv background comes in.
Because when you're on the stage
and you're just sort of winging it,
and you have this feeling like,
oh my god, I think I'm
dying in this scene.
Then somebody comes in and saves you.
And so having learned that
and having participated in improvs,
you just get a feeling.
So I think that as editors,
there's a lot of times
when a director will say,
"Why did you pick that take?"
And I go, "Well, 'cause it felt right."
- Absolutely.
- Basically, you're not gonna say,
"Well, I'm discounting your feelings,"
because that's a whole
other (laughs) conversation.
But you just feel the scene.
And for any of the students
wanting to get into editing,
you have to trust your
instincts, you know?
- That's another great
lead-in to this question of,
if a director is especially attached
to one shot or sequence
and you believe it kills the
momentum of the film at large,
how do you have that conversation?
You were touching on it right there.
Trusting your instincts.
- Well, you have a very
gingerly conversation
because their egos are about, you know?
Or about this big.
What I do, is I propose it.
I'll say, "You know what?
I don't think we need this shot,"
or "I feel it's slowing the momentum."
And they go like, "No, I don't think so."
And you go, "Okay," you leave it alone.
Work on the other scenes.
Then you come back and then you go,
"You know what?
I still feel that it's
stopping the movie."
And they'll kinda look at me and I go,
"Okay, I'm dropping it.
I'm not gonna revisit
this until the very end."
And so as we're being brutal
with putting our movie in shape,
that's when we become ruthless.
Ruthless in the way
you're servicing the film,
not ruthless because he
editor has an ego that,
oh, you know, okay, two
points for him and two for me
so now we're at a draw.
And so I bring it back up.
And I go, "You know, I've been watching it
and the last three cuts," I said,
"It's stopping the scene
and stopping the momentum of the movie."
And they'll finally go, "Yeah, yeah.
All right, take it out."
Or if there is a scene
that is really in between
two other scenes, right?
And you go, "We don't need this scene.
We already know what's gonna happen.
The dialogue is giving us
foreshadowing everything,
so we don't need it."
And they'll kinda look at me and I go,
"Here's what you do.
Put it in your next movie.
Get that little card and
put it in your next movie."
And I think I do it with humor
because our job is to
facilitate their vision,
and the ego is creating the
best film we can together,
and being a good collaborator.
And then there are, maybe once in a while,
there are editors, or no, directors,
that are writers.
When I'm interviewing with a
director who's also a writer,
and my question is, "Are
you going to be holding on
to things that you've written?"
"Oh, no, no, no, no, I'm
really good with that."
And then when you get down it it's like,
"No, we really need that scene."
And I'd look at them, I go,
"What did you tell me in
that first interview?"
And so it is sitting and
watching the movie a lot.
And that's when people ask, they say,
"Well, don't you get bored
watching the scene over and over?"
And I go, "Well no,
because I'm looking at different things."
I don't know about you, Dody,
but we're always looking
at the whole frame.
It isn't just the performance.
- Absolutely.
And what I'm hearing is this
really intimate relationship
that you're developing
with your directors.
So you have those
conversations in the interview,
and then you actually are bringing it back
when you're working together.
And I think that's fantastic.
So I have a few more questions.
These come from some of
the students in Kenya.
If you have any interaction
with them on the color grading
with the director in
the finishing product,
and how that works,
and if you wanna say anything about that.
And how it affects the
overall emotion of the film.
- Well, I think that our job,
we start our job when
they first start shooting.
Though I wish that we started sooner
because I think we have a
lot of input into scenes
and the overall look, or
the sound that's involved.
So I'll give you sort of a timeline
and that'll explain that question.
Editors start on the
first day of shooting,
and then they finish shooting,
we present our cut to the director,
the director looks at it,
and then at that time we
start having discussions
about the sound of a scene,
the overall look of the movie.
And so once he's happy with his cut
and we're locking the picture,
I stay on to supervise
the color correction,
the sound of the movie, we're on the mix,
the movie, we talk to the composer.
And we're the keeper of
how it looks, you know?
We speak for the director.
I mean, when I'm in a situation,
when I'm working with Tyler,
he leaves after his cut and I take over.
And I do all of the color correction,
I'm on the stage listening to the sound,
making sure it's what he wants,
and talking to the composer.
The music, where it should be cued.
We have sessions, what we
call spotting sessions,
meaning the sound effects
supervisor comes into my room
along with the visual
effects supervisor, you know?
And the music supervisor and the composer.
So we sit and we run through the movie,
and we stop and go.
And the composer would
say, or I would say,
"Tyler wants music in here,"
or they just get a feel of it.
And we're talking through
this whole process.
And the sound supervisor
gets to see the whole movie,
so he has an idea of
what it should sound like
in certain scenes.
And then we go off and we do our jobs,
and the composer invites
me to listen to the score.
And I tell people, "Look, you know what?
I'm here representing Tyler,"
and I'm here representing
any of the directors I've worked with.
I said, "So, if I ask you to do something
and you think it's not
something you wanna do,"
I said, "Well, you know,
first of all let me know
and we talk about it.
But a bottom line is,
if it gets screwed up
then I'll take the responsibility.
I'm not gonna put it on you.
But we're here to do a job together."
Which leads me, in terms of the sound
and the color of the picture,
when we were doing "The Joy Luck Club",
if you examine that, if you
look at that movie closely,
there are no dissolves or
fade-outs in that entire movie,
in that two hour and 15 minute movie.
And the reason for that was,
when I was talking to
Wayne Weng, the director,
I said, "How are we gonna
deal with transitions?"
I said, "I'm not a fan of
dissolves or fade-outs,
but if you want them, we're gonna do it."
And he goes, "Well, we're
gonna do an A-B on it,"
which means they do it in the lab.
You don't get to see it
before it goes to the lab.
And I said to him, I go,
"Well, that's scary."
I said, "I don't like that,
because I don't get to see
how the dissolve works."
Because sometimes you put
a dissolve in and you go,
oh my god, you gotta
start noodling with it.
But because they do it in the lab,
it's done.
You can't undo it unless you
go back and redo that thing.
So I said to Wayne, he and I decided,
well, how about this?
Why don't we do sound effects?
So in that movie, the four
women were different elements.
One was water, one was fire,
one was wood, one was wind.
And so especially the scene where Lindo,
the woman that gets married
off to this young boy,
when she decides to get out
of this arranged marriage.
At the end when she
tells her mother-in-law
that the maid is actually
carrying her son's baby,
and that's how she got
out of that marriage.
And so the line goes, "Well,
Huang Taitai got her grandson
and I got a one-way ticket to Shanghai."
And so in that scene, when
you hear that narration,
the narration bridges us
into the past-present.
And on top of that, you
hear the sound of a train
crossing that scene, and
it morphs into cable car,
which is, now we're in San Francisco.
- That's great.
I love that.
So you're using audio as your
transition instead of visual.
And if it's effective
and it's doing all that,
then it brings the audience in.
Or like I like to say,
the sound sucks you into the next scene.
- Right.
And we did it throughout
the whole movie, you know?
On a subliminal level.
And it worked really well in that movie.
Which brings me to, I think
there was a question about,
are there things that we create
that are not in the script
to help forward the movie?
And a scene, once again
"The Joy Luck Club",
where the scene is with the same woman,
Ying-Ying and her daughter
living in this crooked house.
And so she's walking around,
and her whole thing is, "I'm
like a tiger on the prowl."
So Wayne comes into my cutting room
and he had this look on his face.
I go, "What's going on?"
And he goes, "Well, I've
been accused of this,
and I guess I'll be accused of it again."
I go, "What is that?"
He goes, "Being abstract."
I go, "Well, let's talk about it."
I go, "What's on your mind?"
And he goes, "Well, I'm
thinking I'm not quite sure
how we bridge this scene
where she's walking around,
and it feels like it could be too long."
And I said, "Well, what
do you think about this?"
'Cause editors and directors,
we actually spend a lot of time talking.
A lot people, when they walk
by the cutting room they go,
"Oh, they're just talking,
they're not working."
But we get a lot of work done
just talking and delving into things.
And I said to him, I go,
"Here's a woman that
kills her baby, you know?
It's 20 years later."
I said, "She's still gonna be
thinking about that almost daily."
I said, "What if we just
cut a bunch of stuff
that builds up to that moment?
And then he had shot the vase breaking,
and it kinda cues the woman
and her husband to look up.
The noise cues them,
something's happened upstairs.
And so that's how that montage came out,
that you see the baby,
you see the bad husband
and the watermelon,
and we accentuated all
those sounds, you know?
And so at the end is when the vase breaks,
and once again, it
echoes through the house,
and that cues the daughter to come up
and to get the final lesson.
- That's great.
I love that.
- That wasn't in the script at all.
So that was a fun one to
work on, create that montage.
- That's true invention
with the material you have,
and really going above and beyond.
And from what you're describing,
obviously your career has
been so busy and jam-packed.
How did you balance work and family,
and coming back to work
after some time off with your children?
How did you balance all that?
And how did you manage to come back?
- Well, I decided to take a hiatus from
working as a sound editor, actually,
because when I worked with Bob,
like on "3 Women", for instance,
he put me in that movie.
And how I got that job was, once again,
I'm walking down the hall
and he looks at me, he goes,
"You're Doris and you're
going to Palm Springs."
I go, "Okay."
I don't know what that means.
But the backstory to that,
there's always a backstory here,
is that I was living with Scotty Bushnell.
We were sharing an apartment.
And one morning the phone rings at like,
6:00 in the morning,
and she's on the phone
for at least two hours.
I get up, shower, I go sit down,
have coffee with her.
And she goes, "Well, that was Bob."
I go, "Oh, really?
What did he want?"
And he goes, "Well, he
had a dream (laughs)
we're doing a movie called
'3 Women'." (laughs)
So that was the reference-
(indistinct)
Which is crazy, right?
- Love it.
- So that's when he pointed to me like,
"Okay, you're Doris,"
who was one of the spa workers.
It turned out Doris was
one of the spa workers.
And so I went to Palm Springs.
And I went to Palm Springs
not only as an actress
but an assistant film editor.
So I was doing double duty here.
And when I was finished acting,
I would help Dennis, my editor,
put the dailies together.
And so, from that point on,
then I would work in...
When we got back, I transitioned
to working in sound.
And so then I became a sound assistant.
And so, one day I'm working on the show,
and this great guy, another mentor,
Bill Stevenson said to me, he
goes, "What are you doing?"
He goes, "You know,
you're a sound assistant.
You're never gonna get
a job being an editor.
You need to go pursue that."
And I kinda looked at
him, I go, "You know what?
You're right."
And so I said, "You know what?
I gotta take time off."
I said, "I gotta regroup
and figure this out."
And so that figuring out took eight years.
So I was on hiatus.
I didn't have a job.
I decided I was having a family,
and it just turned into
an eight-year hold.
My husband's also in the business.
He was a gaffer.
So he worked, and I stayed at home
taking care of my two boys.
But I did something, I
guess it was intuitively.
And this is advice I give to men and women
who are deciding to start a family.
I said, "Every month I would
call up Bill Stevenson,
or I'd call up the editors
that I had work with,
and I go 'Hey, you guys wanna
go have coffee or lunch?'"
And we'd spend a couple hours
having coffee and lunch.
And so then my husband
had a really bad year.
He had worked with this one cameraman
and they had a big falling out,
so my husband was out of work,
and I was out of work for a whole year.
And so I said to him, I go,
"Okay, I gotta get back to work,"
because I'm a member
of the Editor's Guild,
which is a union.
And I was in good standing
'cause I paid my dues.
And so I called up Bill, and I said,
"Hey, Bill Stevenson," I said,
"I'm looking for a job.
Do you have a job?"
And he said to me, he goes,
"Well, I don't have anything
for at least a month."
He goes, "But I can't pay you much,"
'cause he was always cheap, right?
And he goes, "I could only
pay you as an apprentice."
I go, "I don't care."
At that time, I think an
apprentice was making like,
$700 a week, which is better
than answering phones.
And so that's what happened.
I worked with him for like...
When his show came in,
he honored that promised,
and I worked with him.
And then during that
time, I was working...
I went to a wedding,
Raja Gosnell's wedding,
who used to be our, Dennis and I,
he was our apprentice and assistant.
Well, now he's a big-time director.
And he was getting married,
and so I saw Dennis at the reception.
And where else would you
meet an editor but at a bar?
And so we stood there,
and he goes, "Hey, I hear you're getting
back in the business."
I go, "Yeah."
I said, "Why?
You have a job for me"
We had a really good relationship
that we could bicker like that, right?
And I go, "What?
You looking for an assistant?"
And he goes, "Yeah, as a matter of fact."
I go, "Oh, really?"
I go, "What happened to
your other assistant?"
I said, "Did she find a better editor?"
And so he goes, "Yeah, she
went on to greener pastures.
Anyways, do you want a job?"
I go, "Yeah.
Yeah, I need a job."
And so he hired me to do "Major League".
So that's how I got back as an assistant.
Then I met Danny Greene
because after that show,
Dennis had another job.
And so there was a
post-production supervisor,
Gloria Clark, and she was really nice.
So that job fell through,
but I helped her on another job.
I went over to her house and
helped her with the list.
I mean, I was just doing my job.
And so what happened was,
she had a friend named Danny Greene
who was a very well-known editor.
He cut "Blazing Saddles", "M*A*S*H",
very well-established editor.
And she said, "Oh, I have a friend
who's looking for an assistant."
I go, "Really?"
And she said, "Yeah.
Can I give him your name?"
I said, "Sure."
And he calls me, and
interviews me over the phone.
And I get hired by Danny Greene.
So I go off and I work with Danny.
And God rest his soul,
Danny's passed away,
but he became a great mentor to me.
And he was super old school,
because back in the day,
editor's loved to go have lunch
in a place where they had a bar. (laughs)
Right?
- Yep.
- And so I-
- (indistinct) Soup to go.
- (laughs) Right?
Wink wink, nudge nudge,
let's go have a lunch at a shi-shi place.
That's what he would call it.
And so we'd go to Musso and Frank's.
Oh my god, we'd go all over Hollywood.
But I noticed that when we'd come back,
he'd sort of sit down at the couch,
and then he'd have the trades,
and the next thing you
know, he was asleep.
So this happened like, the whole week.
And before the end of the week,
Wednesday or something like that,
I go, great, so what am I gonna do?
Read the script again?
So finally one day,
I knew he was just
about ready to doze off.
I go, "Listen," I go,
"Hey, Danny, would you
mind if I work on a scene?"
And he goes, "Knock
yourself out, darlin',"
and off, (snores) off he'd go.
(laughs) So, I'd work on a scene.
And the only reason I asked him that
was because we were working in tandem.
So he'd be working on the bigger machine,
I'd work on the smaller machine,
and he'd go, "Okay, at this point
I need a closeup on this actor, okay?"
Off I go, I look, cut it, hand it to him.
He'd splice it in.
This would go on.
He never said to me, he
goes, "Why'd you pick that?"
He'd just put it in and then we'd play it.
So I kinda knew that we were in sync.
So I finally said to him, I go,
"Okay, hey listen, Danny,
while you're relaxing, would
you mind if I work on a scene?"
And he goes, "Oh, knock
yourself out, darlin'."
- Relaxing.
Anyways.
So I'd work on a scene.
Then about 5:00 I'd go, tap, tap, tap,
"Hey, Danny, before we go home,
would you mind looking
at what I did today?"
And he'd get up, he'd look at the scene.
And he'd look at it, and
he'd take something out
and then splice it together
or rearrange something.
And then he goes, "There."
I'd go, "Oh, great.
Thank you."
So then the next day
I'd do the same thing.
And he'd look at the scene, and he goes,
"What's wrong with it?"
I go, "I don't know.
It feels good."
And he goes, "Yeah, it's great."
So that was our...
That was my mentorship that I
actually had a teacher there.
And not one time did he look at me like,
well, that's a stupid cut, or
what are you thinking about?
And so he became very
helpful in my transition.
- That's great because he's
giving you license to edit.
You didn't have to get
the job to do the editing.
You were there and he was
mentoring you in the moment,
right on site there,
and it wasn't a question
about someone having to believe in you
when you didn't have an editing credit.
I have one more question.
Do you have any advice
for student film editors?
- Well, I think the important thing is,
if you're going to school
and there's a film program,
volunteer to cut the master
thesis for the students.
Any kind of hands-on will
help you in the future.
And don't be afraid to tell people
what your goal is, you know?
What you wanna do,
because there are a lot of people,
as you can tell, there are a lot of people
that are willing to help you
if you stay enthusiastic,
you keep out of people's way.
And the main thing is to
listen and to observe,
because by listening and observing
the way Robert Altman worked,
I was able to formulate
my own style of editing.
And I think that there's
so many opportunities now
for people to do what we do.
And if you can't go to a school,
just lookin the want ads.
Because I'm sure that in the want ads
there're industrials, films
are really in demand too,
because you know that Microsoft,
and my son who is an editor,
he did a lot of promos for Microsoft.
Now, you never would think that
Microsoft or Google or Yahoo
would have that kind of department.
Or any major, like Proctor and Gamble.
I mean, those places, I think...
And even in then...
Well, I don't wanna suggest
anybody join the Army,
(laughs) but those areas have film editing
because they want to do recruiting films.
And I know that some of the older editors,
that's how they got their start,
was editing recruiting
films for second world war.
But I think you just need
to keep your goal in mind.
And don't let anybody discourage you
because I think that part of it is,
they're just jealous that
they don't have the guts
to do what you wanna do.
And that happened, like
in the reunion where,
high school reunion where
one of the most popular boys
when I was going to school came up to me
and said to me, he goes, "You know what?
I'm really jealous of you."
And I go, "Why?"
And he goes, "Because you went and did
what you wanted to do."
And if I, a woman that grew
up in Vancouver's Chinatown,
can do what I'm doing now,
then anybody can do it.
- And I would say, just always be open,
always be learning,
continue to meet people
who are following the
path that you wanna meet,
and like you said, go for it.
- And I think, Dody, part
of it too is networking.
If you go to school and
you meet a couple people
you really are in sync with,
well then they'll know two more people
and those people would
know four more people.
And so I always suggest
that to new members
in the Editor's Guild,
when they ask "How do I become an editor?"
Well, that's what you do,
is you find all these people.
That's why people that go
to universities do so well,
like Barry Jenkins and Joy MacMillan,
who used to be my assistant,
they all went to Florida State.
So there is a group of support,
so if anybody needs a job,
they know somebody that
will turn you on to a job.
- Right, absolutely.
- Yeah, just keep your eye on the prize.
That's what I say.
- Right. Eye on the prize.
Well, Maysie, thank you so much
for generously sharing your
insights and inspiration
through your rich stories,
your diverse experiences,
your deep wisdom.
And it's really been great
to get to know you actually better.
And I applaud that you're
opening up the world
of film editing to so many people,
and especially to our students in Kenya.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for participating
in the Academy's Visiting
Artist Film Series,
FilmAid Edition for Film Editing.